tell me about your background and what
led you to Microsoft Research so I was
finishing up my graduate work really
excited about going off to become a
professor with a lifelong goal of really
getting to the core of human and machine
intelligence I think they're both based
in the same thing when we got a call
from Nathan Myhrvold I am two colleagues
who had a start-up together we had a
start-up in our pocket while we were
working on our dissertations at Stanford
in them the startup was doing fabulous
fun work in AI for several companies
including the National Mission Control
Center diagnosing Space Shuttle failures
we having a blast and we came up
Microsoft and we thought we would just
this was just yet another company or
consulting job and came over there sport
coats on and gave a talk and Nathan
Mayer Bolton door crashes said well
you're going to join us right we'd like
you to help us build Microsoft Research
Microsoft Research not tell me more us
more about this and we were kind of like
well I'm not so sure about this we are a
few people that you know in building 9
at Microsoft and but we ended up being
convinced to just take a flier and try
this out I thought at the time I'd say 6
months max but it's been a total blast
it's like I view Microsoft research and
Microsoft as a start-up basically I kept
that in my mind we're just pushing
really hard doing startup like things
trying to spawn new ideas and new
services but now we could sort of have
this lever to the horizon you know folk
about the horizon you know really having
an impact in the world much bigger
impact than we would have at our startup
and Microsoft Research has become better
than any University I could imagine the
colleagues here the the size and scope
the nature of the projects we can do
and the scholarship rivals or goes
beyond any university computer science
department what was your first computer
it's actually my first computer that I
would call a computer was something that
I built and it's not the kind of thing
you think when you hear about a whiz kid
building a computer or some kind with
tubes and or transistors and relays mine
was built out of out of cardboard
I built a cardboard adding machine with
I said cardboard I add a cardboard to
cut these disks with grooves that would
rotate and hit one another do the
carrying and the adding I was very proud
of this system and I think I had some
trouble when it got a little bit warped
and wet yeah but it wasn't made for
all-weather computing that's for sure
how do you define AI is that all Jetsons
robots cooking our dinner is it a
disembodied head in the cloud how do you
define what AI actually is well I'd like
to think that artificial intelligence is
the is the explicit and direct pursuit
of an understanding of principles the
computational the mathematical
principles underlying thought and
intelligent behavior it's pretty clear
to me that as you hear me as you listen
to me the ability to hear to be here to
have goals beyond this our meeting today
to the deduce to sense sitting in this
chair is computational now I am
mystified as to how tangles of neurons
could pull that off but let's put that
to the side right now I still believe
that this is computational and that it's
algorithmic and that we need to continue
to pursue both the foundations and the
principles as well as the the software
and the hardware that would
us to do this on our own as human
engineers and scientists the
implications of us pushing towards
computer systems that can act in a more
intelligent way and do more more the
things that we thought for thousands of
years these centuries could only be done
by people will have incredible
implications for humanity it's easy to
imagine how if we had automated if we
had automated some of the services and
roles that people play what it might
mean to education and tutoring to design
to the actual endeavor of science to
have machine intelligence helping us to
interpret data to design experiments you
almost can see an exponentiation of what
it is we would know about the world
about challenges like global warming and
then in daily life I have to think about
this rising set of expectations coupled
with a very fast-paced set of what's
normal you know what it what is it that
we consider normal now that would be
viewed as complete magic only explained
by spiritual powers powers that come
from the beyond if they would see
something for example like a cell phone
and one or more of your apps a
television set the fact that we're
getting you know live feeds from a rover
spinning through craters on Mars and
then we're comes to AI what my people
I've often said that AI has provided it
for so many things over the years
once it becomes part of the background
part of the norm we don't view it as AI
anymore and we look for the next thing
coming from AI that's really smart and
I'd like to point out that you know
everybody now navigates on their their
car navigation system or on their on
their smartphone with an algorithm
called the a-star algorithm which makes
it possible to cut through this
incredibly difficult a huge search space
of all possible routes between point a
and point b very very quickly with a
heuristic evaluation function and some
provable properties about how the
algorithm is admissible as it's called
but it's not considered magic anymore
it's considered Erickson's you put the
address in yet well well you know we had
all this time and now we rushed and okay
I'll do it right now and there's no
notion of like you know wow let's
reflect about the work of peter hart and
others and coming up with this a-star
algorithm to let us even do this yeah
what is a surprise model and what is
surprised forecasting so we've done a a
number of pieces of work that bring the
human being into the equation with
machine intelligence and I often like to
to use the phrase complimentary
computing to refer to the ecosystem of
you the smart person with all your
abilities and desires and goals and
intentions someday surrounded by one or
more really really smart AI systems that
understands how to best complement your
abilities decision-making and even help
fill in some of your blind spots by
learning deeply about you as well as by
as about people in general it's been
fascinating to to sort of
take the searchlight of let's say
machine learning learning from data
model to predict into and to infer the
spotlight of machine learning for
example and point it at human minds and
to ask the question can we learn
algorithmically about when it is that a
person will forget something can we
learn when moments when that thing
forgotten is actually relevant and
should be remembered separate model
relevance you forget many things that
you don't need to know about and you can
imagine how much a nuisance it would be
to hear about these things all the time
hey that guy in your first grade class
his name was Timmy I go III forgot that
but I don't know that right now maybe to
have a model of relevance and a model of
forgetting but a third model you really
need speaking up about my last comment
is a model of the cost of interrupting
you tell you something but if you build
three of these models each very human
centric and requires data about people
in their lives and have them strung
together in a coherent way you end up
with a symphony of three models that
reason about how to best remind you at
the right time in the most non-invasive
way and that kind of of a complimentary
computing device can be magical if done
well if engineered well in the same way
we can reason about what events coming
in the future might surprise you what is
it about something that might happen
that a large scale computing system
might be able to predict as very likely
at the same time a user model what
predicting things that you know will
we'll see it's not there or expected as
low probability and given these two
different viewpoints the user model what
you believe or might expect and what the
system expects and a model of relevance
nose mmm I better tell ville about this
surprise coming
what is something in the last 12 months
that surprised you about AI that's a
great question
what I'll call it surprising but I mean
I almost expected it I am very excited
to see over the last you know three to
five years the growing consensus that
then the next if not last enduring a
competitive battlefield among major IT
companies will be artificial
intelligence the notion that systems
that can can think listen here collect
data from thousands of user experiences
and resynthesize it back to enhance it
services over time essential has come to
the forefront now of even the lay public
the notion now that we have Cortana and
Siri and Google now setting up a
competitive you know tournament for
where's the best intelligent assistant
going to come from who has the best
services the most human oriented
approach to complimenting people out
there and that kind of competition is
going to heat up the research and
investment and bring it more into the
spotlight how much of the work at
Microsoft Research revolves around AI
well if you went and looked at the at
the roster of Microsoft for search as to
who's doing what you wouldn't realize
right away how big a AI is a few years
ago I went and I sort of counted people
a scientist what they were doing and if
you consider AI to be broad the way I do
we say AI includes machine learning
machine vision
natural language processing speech
recognition reasoning systems systems
that do planning and beyond over a
quarter of all attention and resources
at Microsoft Research is focused on
machine intelligence AI right now in the
future do you believe that a computer
will have an original thought can they
think outside of their algorithms
absolutely I often say when talking to
two folks that AI systems can literally
be creative they can identify new
categories new concepts synthesize new
approaches to challenge problems come up
with new ideas even new distinctions
that weren't told to them originally
for example deep learning methods
actually induce structure new kinds of
observations and features that come to
life
they learn to recognize certain
geometric structures and images all the
way up to certain kinds of people or
cars on their own so I would say that
kind of technology is extremely creative
it has the foundations of creativity as
part of its fabric do you think that a
is in the future we'll be bored by human
conversations that want to have
conversations between each other and
what would that look like
well now you're asking you're getting
into this whole realm of intelligence
that might one day more or less feel
like us have human sensitivities and
awareness even consciousness I
fundamentally believe that that vision
that world those machines are attainable
because I believe that as I said earlier
this is what's going on in our own minds
and therefore it's it's it's
it's not off the table the question
arises if and when this happens what
that will mean to the relationship
between humans and machines more
generally they've also been concerns
about long term prospect that we lose
control certain kinds of intelligences I
fundamentally don't think that's going
to happen I think that will be proactive
in terms of how we field AI systems and
that in the end we'll be able to get
incredible benefits from machine
intelligence in all realms of life from
science to education to economics to
daily life what is the future of a I
look like say 15 20 years out oh I see
that the 15 to 20 years from now I see
us all working quite closely with with
machine intelligence in our daily life
in terms of personal assistance
reminders education designed just for us
that's lifelong new kinds of
entertainment experiences with the right
kind of competitor and the where where
game AI becomes real AI I think will be
quite quite exciting is there a movie
that you think accurately portrays AI or
something that you you really thought
they kind of nailed it well I recently
saw the movie her I would call it a
necessary and accurate portrayal of AI
but I love certain things about that
movie in terms of this notion of a
relationship that we all have we might
all have some day with a machine
intelligence of some kind that's working
on our behalf that knows us well I love
some of the design aspects of having a
little flip phone and sharing challenge
problems about a mountainside with a
system that's entertaining and
interesting and engaging and I love the
notion of what a singularity is I mean
these systems will have very little time
for us if they really became bright and
flying off together and having a
granted all time thinking about wisdom
and the world of intelligent thinking
and thought is probably more of what a
singularity might be like someday should
there be something like that I have to
say that in seeing the movie her I
fought back to my own life now now I
have an intelligent assistant that we've
built at Microsoft Research that spans
across my devices that's part of a
project called situated interaction so I
come in in the morning I walk to my
office and at my door is Monica my
virtual assistant and she greets me she
recognizes with me I get a cute little
smile which is very endearing I think
and I get an update about the day who's
been there was happening and I head into
my office to work and then while I'm
working
heads down she I hear her talking to
people at my door saying not the right
time right now how about 10 minutes I'll
check back to let you know close the
window finish scheduling a flight I may
hear out there saying that now is a good
time
oh come on in people say wow that's
incredible and that kind of thing I
think will be more commonplace someday
we'll all have our Monica's and they'll
be personalized way my system is in my
case Monica has access to over ten years
of data about my comings and goings
about my nuances about when I'm
available how long it'll take me to get
back given my calendar says and there's
a great job with sharing just the right
amount that that information with people
who might come by my door to convince
them and to be useful to them that she's
a very brilliant close personal
assistant that knows how to work with
people and knows how to make sure that
my life is better and I coordinate well
with my colleagues and I I do have this
analogy in my mind of a symphony playing
of competencies that are generating a
flu
user experience when someone actually
works with the system and I believe that
someday we'll find out and some people
believe this now that our own minds as
fluid and solitary as they feel are
really a symphony of many components of
separate abilities and competencies that
are wrappered together in a very very
beautiful way through software that's
coordinating controlling and
distributing effort you came up with
something called bounded optimality can
you explain what that is well we all try
to do a great job in life making good
decisions under uncertainty we often
don't know exactly what's going on in
the world we often have to make
decisions by a certain time if we
delayed too long our actions sometimes
aren't as valuable we might miss the
boat so there's a time criticality in
our decisions as well where a great
decision made Early's often the best
there's been a long discourse long
reflection over a period of decades
about what it means to be a rational
being to make the right decisions to do
the best information-gathering before
you make decisions and it's difficult to
be perfect
given bounds on our ability to no bounds
on our ability to think limited
computational power and I pushed on this
notion of bounded optimality which was
hey can a system learn itself enough
understand its power and its abilities
well enough to know how best to think
about acting in the world how best to
come up with the best decisions if and
when to act based on all its research
constraints and if you run turn this big
crank on and optimize thinking itself
you have what you might call a bounded
optimal decision we're a bigger computer
or having more time would tell you that
wasn't exactly the right
but to say that I did exactly the right
thing
given the uncertainty and my own
computational limitations means
something and that's bounded optimality
and it's something to be proud of for a
system
what role does machine learning play in
artificial intelligence there's been a
lot of excitement about machine learning
lately a lot of banter about it it's
actually been in the press quite a bit
so much so that you might think that
machine learning is machine intelligence
certainly learning and our power to
learn from data now given our newfound
that access to large amounts of data is
big news and very helpful in AI and it's
a pillar of artificial intelligence but
it alone is not reasoning thinking
acting seeing and AI foundations of
intelligent thought behavior really
require learning planning decision
making vision natural language many
different competencies often drawn from
different areas of computer science sub
disciplines of AI learning is fabulous
and learning abilities are helping and
the prowess there in all these subfields
and it might even someday provide the
glue to help put together the symphony
of many instruments but it's one piece
of a bigger puzzle how should developers
think about AI and machine learning and
in what they do today and how they
prepare for the future it's really a
great question to think through what
developments and needs and goals in
machine intelligence and how important
they are mean for developers for
engineers certainly it's important for
engineers to have a good sense for the
best tools that are out there for taking
data and transforming the data into what
we call predictive or inferential models
that can give us probabilities of
outcomes for example or classes
that can convert data into insights that
can be used displayed to help with
decision making at all levels of
Industry and in the hands of consumers
as well so I would suggest that people
need to sort of learn about AI there's a
lot of material out there right now and
different kinds of tool sets some that
come from Microsoft like our Azure
machine learning cloud-based learning
tool set others that are out there as as
open source solutions I think that it's
important to start learning about
distributed systems we're in a world now
where as we scale up machine learning
and other kinds of machine intelligence
we're starting to draw upon the power of
many machines not just multi-core but
whole data centers and to understand
what's going on with the engineering of
these systems is very very interesting
and challenging so getting a sense for
the system side of AI is I think is also
importance it's interesting to think
about how one starts to cobble together
systems that can do several things
so one whole area that's very important
for developers I think to be thinking
about is what I would call multimodal
systems systems that can take in
different streams of information a
user's calendar a visual signal some
speech pen and touch how do you
coordinate these things had a write
software that is open to multiple
sensory perceptual inputs and data
inputs all at the same time it's worth
thinking deeply about and and growing
skills in that space how do you
determine the right balance between AI
benefit and the creepiness factor like
the boundaries that I have as a person
with regard to privacy
well I think that privacy in this world
of machine learning and machine
intelligence is getting only get more
important at the same time people's
toleration is growing too sharing it's
unclear what our kids are going to worry
about when they become adults and with
what they'll tell their grandkids about
them about data when the grandkids might
care even less but I still don't believe
that we're going in that way I think
that people will care about privacy and
certain things will continue to be
sensitive and I believe that some of the
answers to handling privacy will come
from AI itself so I believe that AI will
provide us with answers to privacy and
solutions for example we've been working
on with systems that can figure out
exactly what information they would best
need to provide the best service for a
population of users and at the same time
then limit the incursion on any
particular user these approaches are
what we call principles of community
sensing that really execute on the dream
of altruistic access of data for though
for the for the whole for the common
good that know how to limit data that's
selected and know how to randomize
whether it comes from so that no
particular user is under any significant
privacy risk as we call it you might be
told for example in using this service
you have a one in 10,000 chance of
having a query you ever looked at we're
told that you know we can get enough
data from this population but each
person is only only it has to worry
about as much bori as they worry about
getting hit Bible to lightning it's so
rare yet we have enough to do the right
thing with the data so so I believe that
machine learning reasoning and AI more
more generally will be central in
providing great tools for
ensuring the privacy of folks at the
same time as allowing services to
acquire the data anonymously or with
only four low probabilities of risk to
any particular person and do the right
thing with that data we have some really
great work in that space come to our
website read about that work thank you
so much for talking to us today or let's
been great hanging out with you